it's been nearly four decades since its
release but John Carpenter's The Thing
still remains one of the greatest horror
films of all time as renowned as it is
for its creature designs lead
performances in deeply unsettling
atmosphere it's also famous for its
ending which leaves more than its fair
share of unanswered questions the film
opens with the classic image of a flying
saucer barreling through space toward
Earth much later we learned that the
craft had crashed on our planet in
Antarctica and according to Norris it
might have been buried in the ice for
100,000 years that's virtually all we
get of the things origin story and like
so much else in the film it poses more
questions than it answers after all that
ship looked mighty sophisticated which
suggests that it was built by an alien
race of considerable technological skill
if that's the case it's entirely
possible that more have been built
meaning it's also possible that other
similar ships made their way to earth at
some point or another have any of them
crashed or even landed is there a whole
fleet out there just waiting for a sign
that there's life on our planet or was
the ship's crash landing the result of a
hideous alien hijacker it's impossible
to tell for sure but the presence of
that ship hangs over the whole movie
it could have imitated a million life
forms on a million planets could change
it to any one of them at any time now it
wants life-forms on earth even if it had
been in some kind of stasis the alien
spacecraft which contained that thing
had been present on our planet for
millennia but even with all that time on
earth the movie doesn't give us the
creatures entire history either it's
possible that all this has happened
before either with another spacecraft or
with the same spacecraft encountered by
other people a lot has changed in a
hundred thousand years and the
spacecraft may not have always been
completely buried in the ice what if
there's alien DNA out in the world right
now spread by somebody who encountered
it many years ago part of the film's
effectiveness comes from the fact that
it leaves those questions unanswered and
dials up the paranoia over just what the
thing is and what it can do but what we
do know is that it can infiltrate
mankind
assimilate seamlessly if it wants to -
who's to say it hasn't already as the
paranoia over who might be infected by
the thing sets in the men of the station
quickly begin to turn on each other
this conflict it's a fever pitch when
nulls tries to leave McCready out in the
storm after finding his torn jacket
outside which suggests that he may have
been attacked at some point child what
if we wrong about him wrong McCready
eventually makes his way back inside and
ultimately takes command of the
survivors but this seemingly vital plot
point is quickly forgotten
is there a logical reason for it to have
been there is it really proof that Mack
was already assimilated and that the
organisms controlling him are just
really good at hiding it or is something
else going on the film never answers
that question but it does feed into the
famous final scene in a major way
the film's iconic blood test sequence
raises another interesting question
about the nature of the thing Palmer is
the one who turns out to be infected and
we see his blood basically jump out of
its petri dish when confronted with a
hot wire we also know that the thing
will divide into different parts that
will act independently if they need to
and that it can infect people on a
microbiotic level does all of this mean
that infected blood get in some way act
or at least survive on its own there's
no short supply of blood scattered
throughout the film both in the
Norwegian station and among the
Americans if it's somehow able to retain
the alien organism within it it could at
the very least survive out in the cold
if it's able to transfer itself to other
tissue it comes into contact with it
could do even more than that fire can
destroy most things but it can't
eliminate every last drop of blood the
thing's ending is famously ambiguous
after destroying the station MacCready
stumbles outside with a bottle of scotch
in hand to find child's returning
claiming his absence from the final
struggle was because he had left to look
for Blair
worried about me we've got any surprises
for each other I don't think we're much
shape do anything this moment has led to
a number of fan theories hypothesizing
which of two men might be infected it
could be either Mac or child's or even
both not only just
wait here for a little while
see what happens some fans claim max
bottle isn't filled with scotch
but gasoline and that he tricked childs
into proving he isn't human by making
him drink it others believe that his
little smile at the end could mean that
Mac is the thing the closest thing to a
definitive answer may have come from
cinematographer Dean Cundy who said he
and carpenter used eye light earlier in
the film to suggest who was human and
who wasn't if you look closely that
could very well mean it's likely the
thing is living in child's whether it's
child's or Macready there is a strong
implication at the end of the film that
at least one of the two men remains
infected by the thing which suggests
that the alien story is far from over
so what happens now if only one of them
is the thing it's quite likely it will
eventually assimilate the other human
body could the thing then hold out long
enough to wait for help could they feign
death and eventually assimilate other
healthier humans could they even let the
ice reclaim them and return to the same
kind of stasis from which the thing
apparently came whatever the case may be
this story clearly doesn't end with
child's and McCready and the version of
Earth the film depicts could well be
doomed check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]